my name is Michelle forward I'm a grad
student linguistics and I love languages
and maps which is why I put together
this thing so it's a linguistic street
map of singapore's so every street is
color coded according to the language of
origin of the street name so this is why
we're going to build today what I used
to build it was data from openstreetmap
use geo pandas to manipulate the data so
I could learn to predict the
classification of the street names and
Tamil to make the map and today's talk
will be mostly focused on scikit-learn
building a baseline classifier and
trying to figure out ways to improve
over that baseline so I'm going to be
talking about the lessons I learned from
building this from building these
classifiers your results on your own
data sets you know just like machine
then learning in general these results
may not generalize to your contacts so
so let's talk about why I wanted to
build this in the first place so if
you've ever been a Singapore you'll see
that the street names are really really
diverse so I some pictures of this is a
obviously a Scottish name this is a
Malay name this is of chinese origin and
i don't have photos of these because i
haven't been back home recently but
there is like Arab names I think this is
a Jewish name and this is an Indian name
so those really names from a lot of
different ethnic origins so why is that
so in case you didn't know save for is
at the southern tip of the malayan
Peninsula it's on the shortest see path
between India and China it was an
important trading port in the 14th
century based on archaeological evidence
we know that but it was probably
important even earlier so follow me and
his geografia had a town called sabana
there was like a trading port at the
southern end of what would have been the
malayan Peninsula and this was in the
first century AD so assuming this was
Singapore it's
been around for a while so that's the
next entry of Singapore into cartography
cartographic history is when emerald
junghwa of china sailed to africa and
india and passed by singapore and this
is actually an excerpt from his
navigational charts and it contains this
landmark which was the dragon tooth gate
which is was a navigate important
navigational landmark for people for
seafarers entering Singapore waters I'm
skipping on so okay so at about this
time there was a Chinese traveler who
pass through Singapore and reported that
it was mostly inhabited by the
indigenous malaise and also there were a
few Chinese Panthers living there um and
like I said before was an important port
in the 14th century but around i think
the 16th or 17th century it was sacked
by the by the portuguese and it became
this sort of sleepy fishing village
which made it a sort of ripe ground to
take over when the British arrived in
1819 so Stanford raffles was looking for
a port in Southeast Asia to challenge
the growing might of the Dutch in the
area and he found Singapore he signed an
agreement with the local chieftain to to
create two to start a port there and
once the British started this port
people started coming in from all over
so by far the most people came from
South China also there were people
moving down from Leia people from Java
sulawesi and Indonesia what is now to
Indonesia from India South India and
also from from Europe so people of all
these ethnic origins came to Singapore
and they settled in these in these
ethnic enclaves in Singapore that were
designated by the authorities so for
example on this map here you can see
there's a European town here and that's
a bogus kompong here that would have
been settled by the lace
and so the people came they settle in
these ethnic enclaves they brought the
names with them and they gave them to
the roads that they lived on ok so I'm
fast-forwarding through a lot in a lot
of history here through World War 2
singapore became independent from from
the british in 1963 and from malaysia in
1965 and one of the first challenge is
that the the new government had was a
huge housing crisis they couldn't
couldn't house everybody the were just
weren't enough homes so they undertook
this really ambitious building program
and built a whole of housing estates
around Singapore and the interesting
thing about these housing estates is
that this ethnic quotas on how many
people of each race lived there so there
has to be a minimum number of minorities
in each in each housing estate as a
result of this because ninety percent of
Singaporeans now live in these in these
public housing towns Singapore has
become very ethnically homogenous but
the road names that people gave to these
places when they first arrived still
remain ethnically heterogeneous so this
is an area of Singapore that actually
I'm from and you can see that all of the
road names in this area are of British
origin right so these are all like
British counties okay so what I wanted
to do was to UM to instead of just you
know looking at the map been trying to
say okay here's a little British spot
here is a little Chinese cluster here i
just wanted to plot everything on a map
once so that i could look at it on a
grand scale so that was what i wanted to
do so where i got the data from was from
open street map in particular there's
these metro extracts for big cities
around the world and i downloaded the
singapore
Street data it came in geo JSON format
geo JSON is basically just JSON accept
that that has this geometry think so
this could be a point in a case of roads
would be a line string and the
coordinates dictate so like how the line
goes so how do we manipulate this data
so i used your pandas which is a variant
of pandas that basically can do a lot of
stuff with geodata so it knows how to
open geo JSON files just like that and
so I open this file and I looked at the
number of roads and it was 59,000 218
and that seems a little bit weird
because Singapore is really small so
it's just 660 square kilometers so why
are there so many roads so with a single
line you can actually plot what's going
on in the geometry of geo pandas and
what it turned out so Singapore's just
this diamond shape here is that we're
getting a lot of data from Malaysia
Indonesia and so what I wanted to do was
to only take those roads that were
within the Singapore administrative
boundaries and this is again really easy
video pandas so I just got the
administrative boundary shape from a
different file and and you can actually
just say take the roads whose geometry
is within the Singapore geometry and you
get the right shape in the end so gia
pandas is an amazing tool if you work
with jas data I recommend checking it
out okay so so at this point we had we
have just the Singapore roads and I did
further amount of filtering and cleaning
and I think I was laughs about 3,000 but
I wanted to go a little bit further
because there's actually a lot of
repetition in the data so these are all
individual street names and in this
particular part of Singapore and you can
see that the urban planners were really
like creative when they got to this area
you know they really busted up with the
source on this one at least
so so basically everything around here
is called lent or except for these two
streets here and instead of classifying
each of these streets individually I
just wanted to to do that um you know
she'd all these as one because these all
obviously of a single ethnic origin so I
just wrote a function that did that's
two strikes out the names and then we
got down to 1711 okay so at this point a
normal person would have sat down and
started you know classifying them by
hand but instead I busted out
scikit-learn so so this was my plan so
what I wanted to do was to take was to
hand code ten percent of the data and
then I would train a classifier based on
this ten percent of the data use it to
predict the labels of the next ten
percent of the data and then I would
have liked to it and then I would hand
correct that and then I'll have twenty
percent of the data that's like you know
properly properly coded and I could use
that to train again and so like in this
iterative cycle hopefully the classifier
getting better and better that was the
idea so this is an example of supervised
classification so let me just go through
this really quickly since I think most
people know what this is about so our
roads are going to be rows in this
feature matrix and we're going to
extract out features which have to be a
numerical based on based on each Road
name we also have this wide train
feature vector which is going to be
basically label switch road so for
example this road is Malaya gets the
labeled zero based on this X train and
white rain by going the classifier will
learn a mapping em between extra and
white rain now we have another data set
that's called and so another set of
roads that we don't yet know the labels
off right so this is our testing data
and we are straight out the same
features based on this
and we can apply the same mapping em
that we learned from X train and white
train to X test to get the predicted set
of labels and then we can compare that
with the the true labels to see how well
we did so this is how supervised
classification goes so what we need to
decide now is so we already know our
roads we already know we've had to
figure out what the set of labels is
we're going to consider we knew figure
out what our features are and we need to
figure out how we're going to learn the
mapping em so the first thing is to
class establish a classification schema
so I chose this so these are the four
main solah ethnicities that were
represented in the in the data generic
is something like like things like
market street or temple street where
even though it's an English word is
clearly not reflecting this British
origin it's just to describe something
about the area and others basically all
the other ethnicities so the next thing
we need to do is to split our data into
the X train and white rain so you can do
that with the Train test fit function
and scikit-learn and then we need to
decide on the features so this is an
example of language classification and
probably the most common set of features
that you use in language classification
is going to be character n-grams so this
is a so shipping overlapping collection
of like one character will be just you
know grams two characters will be by
grams and three characters will be
trigrams so those are those were the
things that I selected as the features
and scikit-learn has has has classes to
do all this counting for you the anger
and counts for you so that's just
conflict to riser and give it the number
of grams you one so this is I think one
two and three and we're going to do on a
character by character basis ok and then
we can so you can use that in Grand
counter and
if it transform the data which is the
road names and this gives us our numpy
feature matrix X train and we do the
same thing with the test data to get X
test okay so next thing we need to do is
figure out how to is to figure out how
we're going to learn that mapping so
psyche learning has this really useful
flow chart to figure out which
classifier to use so if you just go from
the start do you have more than 50
samples yes we do are we predicting a
category IE is this classification or
regression of its classification so we
move here you have labeled data is it
supervised or not yes it is so we move
here it's less than 100k samples yes it
is so we're going to try using linear
SVC ok so the link classifier is really
easy so we just say classifier equals
linear SVC and then we fit that to the
Train X train and white rain and it
learns that mapping or the model M next
thing we need to do is to decide on the
evaluation metric how we're going to
determine how well the how well the
model does so this should be based on
what your downstream what you're going
to do with the data after you've
classified it so what I was going to do
was to individually so I alter the
things that were incorrect so what so
what I want to minimize it's a number of
errors so in other words what I want to
maximize is the accuracy score so I fig
accuracy score as my metric so now we
test the classifier so we want to get
the predictions of the model the
predicted labels so we just apply the
model that we learned before called the
predict method on it apply it to X test
and we get Y test and then we can
compare that white s to the true the
true labels that I hand coded and what
we got what I got in the initial thing
was 0.56
okay so that's 54 six percent that's
thirty four percent of the things that
would have to hand code and you know
change by hand so this is this doesn't
sound really great on the other hand is
much it's doing much better than chance
so there's about six label so maybe so a
completely random classifier we only get
sixteen percent right so so we're doing
quite a bit better than that but we want
to improve so how can we improve so
looking back at this diagram again what
can we change so one thing we can change
is the number of rows we have so we can
change the amount of training data you
can also change the features that we use
and we can change how the mapping is its
perform so in other words we can add
more training data we can experiment
with other classifiers we can add more
features or we can prune the features
and another thing we can do is to tune
the hyper parameters of the classifiers
okay so the first thing that I tried
because it was the easiest and this is
sort of like a post-hoc analysis after I
gone through all the data was to see
what are the effects of data and
classifier type so so you can't really
see the labels but what I was expecting
was that the in your SBC it's sort of a
simple model I was expecting it to do
pretty well on the on the small amount
of training data but as the added
training data expected more powerful
models to do better than it but actually
that wasn't the case so that the top one
is actually linear SVC and it's
basically the best throughout more
powerful models that are expected to do
better such as random force actually
like down here at the bottom it never
really got going at all so that was sort
of surprising another thing to notice is
that you know as we go from left to
right the amount of the accuracy does go
up but sometimes you know it goes down
which is a little bit weird so the
lessons learned from this is that
the more data the merrier mostly so one
thing that it would be good to do if
you're doing if you're thinking about
adding more data is to actually plot how
what the effects of of adding more data
have been so far and just monitoring to
see that it's it's actually increasing
what something that's quite common is
that you have started plateau out after
after a while and and so if you still
insist on adding more data than you're
not going to get very much bang for your
buck so plotting this sort of accuracy
alliances it's a good thing okay so why
do the powerful models not do so well so
it's generally said that powerful models
need a lot of data so maybe it was just
the case that you know with my thousands
something data points it just wasn't
good enough and maybe that was the case
but we'll see you later that there
wasn't a whole story but another thing
to take away from this is that simple
models such as this linear spc can be
extremely effective so don't discount
them okay so the next thing that I'm
going to talk about is how to add
features and I'm going to sort of like
take a little bit of a detour to talk
about pipelines so pipelines so before
what we were doing was that we were
putting our data so the row names start
here we're putting them to it through an
n-gram counter and then using a linear
spc classifier on on that and what i was
doing before was to just um so if like
apply a function to to the data to get
this and then apply another function to
the data to get that and one thing that
you can do is to actually put everything
into a pipeline so so so up to here this
is exactly the same as what we did
before but now I'm going to make a
pipeline of the Ngram counter and the
classifier and then I can use
the entire pipeline and do fit
transformed on the on the original data
so this is going to be the road names
and the labels in one shot instead of
doing each step individually and and
that gets us the model and then we can
do the usual model predict so the
advantage of using pipelines is that you
can you can chain together a lot of
different steps really easily and have
this single object that you can save and
reuse later and it's very readable so I
recommend using pipelines so what do we
what do we want to add our new feature
that sort of like our own feature and
not not using like count vector riser to
count the number of engrams so so one of
the features that I thought to add was
to count the number of words in the road
name and the reason i thought this would
be was this might be useful was that the
more words you have the more likely is
going to be to be of chinese origin
right because chinese names often have
two or three words in them so what i
need is a new data transformer that
takes road names and outputs this number
okay so so how do you write your own
transformers so you can write your own
transform a class so this was a so this
is a very generic transformer class that
I wrote I just called it applied
transform and what transformers need to
do is they need to have a transform
function that actually takes your numpy
array x and outputs another numpy array
and it also needs this fit fit method
but it's almost always the same it just
return itself it doesn't need to do
anything else so what apply transform
does is that it's going to apply a
function f element wise to an umpire ray
and so when I so I can make a word count
pipeline that takes
that takes road names and and returns
the number of words in your own name
okay so we want to use this word count
transformer in parallel with the
original and graham counter right we
don't want to chain them because you
know that's not that's they're both
acting on the same data which is the
road name so make pipeline was a was
always cereal so how do we put these
things in parallel and the answer is is
feature unions so this is another
feature of sight given pipeline and
there's a function called make union
that allows you to parallel eyes two or
more transformers and so what you can
pass it why you passin can either be a
transformer such as the Ngram counter
which was you know the count vector
riser is just a transformer or you can
also pass in a whole pipeline so this
could actually be two or three steps and
you could put them in parallel okay so
we make a pipeline out of this out of
these parallel transformers and the
classifier and that's the complete set
of steps that we need to do in order to
in order to it in order to make our
model m this is another useful
transformer so sometimes your data is
going to have several your numpy array
is going to have several several columns
in it and sometimes you want your you
only want to operate on a single column
or several columns and you can actually
use this column selector transformer to
to just select the columns you want and
then chain that to another transformer
that acts just on those columns and and
goes what goes on from there ok so what
additional features did I try so um this
is the this is like the stage in in
machine learning where you really get to
use your domain knowledge so
once so that one of the things was like
I said before a number of words in a row
name another thing that I thought to use
was the average length of the word so
for example Indian names tend to be
quite long china chinese words chinese
names tend to have each word quite short
so i thought this might be a
discriminator feature another one was
whether all of the words were in the
dictionary so so remember those that
generic label so if so Market Street the
web market is definitely going to be in
a dictionary so so all of the words
being in the dictionary is a good
predictor that it's generic class
another one which is not directly
inherited from the street name is
whether the road type is Malay so
streets of Singapore usually end in
street or road just like here but
there's also streets that start with
jalan which is the Malay word for street
and long which is setting the mother
would word for lane and so and streets
that have that start with jalan alor on
I have a very very high probability of
being Malay so this was also a good a
good feature to use so I added these
features on top of the engrams and
plotted how how he did so this purple
line at the bottom is just n grams so
and then the next step that I did was to
add whether it was the Malay road tag
weather had the Malay road type or not
and that brought me up a few percentage
points to here is the green one and then
I added the average word length and the
number of words and that didn't increase
increase the accuracy by very much and
and then I tried all of the word whether
all of the words when dictionary adding
that feature and we got quite a big
boost in accuracy so what's the takeaway
from this so why i think that the
average word length and the
number of words in didn't add that much
to the accuracy was that we all sort of
duplicating old information this was
sort of encoded in the Indian grams so
but when we added fresh information that
wasn't in the Ngram such as whether had
the malay road type or whether all of
the words were the dictionary these are
things that couldn't possibly be in the
end grams so adding this fresh
information really helped to improve the
model ok the next thing we can do is to
try feature selection so this is when
you call the features and you discard
the ones that aren't very predictive in
general it said that this reduces the
risk of overfitting to your training
data so this is when you predict that
you fit to the training data so well
that you can't generalize to the testing
data and that this will improve accuracy
so psychic learning comes with a bunch
of feature selection methods such as
select percentile l1 base feature
selection in principle components
analysis there are many more these are
the ones that I tried and how you use
them as basically you can slot them into
your feature pipeline after you've
created your future matrix and before
you do the classifier and what I found
those that it didn't help it's all for
me basically the highest performing one
this orange line up here is the one
where there's no feature selection going
on at all so I don't want to say that
I'm not saying that feature selection is
is it's a bad thing to do but that
definitely doesn't necessarily help and
you probably want to think about using
it when your model is definitely over
fitting to the data or you really have a
very large number of features that you
know it so is taking a long time to
train your classifier but otherwise you
know it's probably not the first thing
that I'll reach for okay and the last
thing that I try was hyper parameter
tuning so so basically each classifier
comes with a bunch of
Piper parameters where that will and
changing them will affect how it learns
the mapping so in order to search
between all of these hyper parameter
settings scikit-learn gives this grid
search CV function and what what it does
is that it will take the pipeline you've
already made so this is I'm just using
this Ngram pipeline and SVC and i'm
doing a grid search on the pipeline and
i'm going to pass it this parameter grid
so this these are the parameters that I
wanted to experiment with so svce has a
few different parameters one of them is
see one of them is gamma so these are
the difference maybe like five different
settings that I want of the sea variable
and a bunch of different settings of the
gamma variable and it will test every
combination of these and see how well
how well it does how well each of them
does and once you've fitted to exchange
my train you can query it for the best
parameters and what I came out with was
gap a gamma value of point 0 1 and C
value of 100 and then you can pass these
back in again and you can make a
pipeline now from the Ngram pipeline and
FCC we see set to 100 and gamma said to
0.001 and I didn't play with around with
this a huge amount is actually really
time consuming but it actually did
really really well so I didn't show you
before but when i tried support vector
classifiers using the default radial
basis function colonel it was one of the
worst performing along with the along
with random force but when i just did
this hyper parameter tuning i got this
huge jump in accuracy so even though it
was time consuming it seems like doing
this type of parameter tuning is worth
it especially and i'll show you this
especially but it certainly worked well
on this complex model okay so
when I first looked at doing grid search
I was actually really really confused
about how to pick the parameter grid I
was like how do you know which parameter
which hypo parameters to tune and how do
you know what what settings to try and
in the abstract I promise that I will
say something something about this and I
think I was hoping that by now I would
know something more something more has
something to say about it but actually I
don't so I'm just going to say that I
think when it comes to picking this
hyper parameter grid this is sort of
like part of the art of machine learning
and really understanding how the
classifier works will help so in
particular want to understand like what
parameters change how powerful the model
is you might want to use these and as
for the values go big so pick the
logarithmically space values if you want
to if you want you can you can do a
second path of grid search afterwards
just searching around in the solar local
vicinity of the values that you found
the way the best but in general pick
logarithmically space by Lewis unless is
bounded so sometimes you know it's just
supposed to take a value between 0 and 1
and then it's a no brainer just pick
equally spaced values so that's one one
way you can do it understand how the
classifier works and the other ways to
just shamelessly copy which is what I've
been doing when I do hyper parameter
search or to see what other people have
done on github and in fact if you look
at the manuals for the libraries that
linear SVC and spc are based on which is
linear and live SPM these are see
libraries they actually have
recommendations for how to set for what
hyper parameters to try so so you could
just follow what they say okay so so
basically I think I stopped more or less
when I got to about 70
percent accuracy and that was good
enough for me and I had corrected the
rest of the data and then it was time to
make the map so so so before I had
remember the Geo JSON data with all of
the different roads and now I had this
classification it data which is sort of
a shorter matrix and is really easy to
merge those two using pandas so just
much it provides this merge function and
when you pass it how equals left it's
basically the equivalent doing a sequel
f join so that's how I got the final
data and I put it into town mill which
is this sort of GUI over map Nick which
is a c++ library for plotting for
plotting maps and it's pretty good so
basically all I needed to do was to add
my data set and to define some what they
call Carter CSS and this is what cardo
CSS looks like so basically I said if
the classification was Malay made the
line color green is really is really
simple to do so so I had my map and and
when I looked at it you know if you
remember how a lot you really do see a
lot of clumping in the data so that's
kind of nice okay so let me summarize my
findings basically so I've tried five
different ways of improving the
classifier and the two that gave me the
most bang for the buck were
understanding the data and adding
informative features based on it and
also tuning the hyper parameters so it
was really time consuming but was with
it also adding more data helped but you
know always watch out for plateauing and
you can use feature selection of your
models overfitting or if you have a
large number of features it didn't help
me actually make then it was but yeah
and the other thing was don't discount a
simple classifiers so remember linear
spc
I'm doing the best out of all the
default classifiers but you know if you
have the data to back them up why not
try the more powerful ones and in
particular you know when you tune the
hyper parameters that may actually do
pretty well okay so yeah that's it and I
have some links but you can't actually
access the links but yeah the map is
online you can look at it so I'm done
thank you sorry thanks sorry yeah I
didn't mention this but um so I found
these two resources really really useful
when so this was really useful for
understanding pipelines in future unions
and thus I could learn tutorial at sify
2013 what has really a lot of good stuff
about about tuning tuning models
which ones needed to be hand corrected
okay yeah so so basically I think just
having grown I'm saying before I have a
sense of which ones like what each thing
should be so I know what like Malay
words look like I don't know it
1,000,000 aims look like I know what the
Chinese names look like and there were
maybe five to ten percent of them were
III couldn't tell and then I had to
actually go and do some like his likes
historical researcher figure out who
this road was named after and stuff like
that
um so I was comparing it to data that I
had already labeled myself yeah other
questions yeah um so I'm thinking of
things like random forests and well I
guess I'm thinking mostly of SVC so if
you take the linear SVC it can only
different that can only differentiate
data that's sort of like linearly
separable more or less but once you use
these other like radial basis functions
and stuff you can actually make these
really like curvy sort of classification
boundaries and you can sort of like
isolate different parts so it's a lot
more powerful in the sense that it can
discriminate a largest larger light sets
of data right I don't mean larger sets
as in there's more data but it's like a
super set of types of data that you can
differentiate that make sense
so in some areas i think that that would
be the case but it so like the places
where there's still private housing
maybe it would still be the case but in
most in most areas singapore has become
like really really homogenous so so
probably not one thing I do want to
explore is like whether it correlates
well with like how people feel about
like the neighborhood boundaries so so
if you go back to this map here so this
is my area of Singapore and I have this
really strong feeling that sort of once
the name start getting different then
it's not really my neighborhood anymore
he like was it has to be like the
Chinese area the valet area yeah so so I
think there might be some correlation
with that maybe yeah
I think some will be much longer than
others so Dean your SVC is very very
fast once you move to light our BF i
think is light n squared so so it's
going to take longer um it was mostly
seconds I mean it's just 1700 well in
most cases even less than that so so
what's the time was just seconds but um
once you start trying so like different
lots of different combinations for
example when you're doing the hyper
parameter tuning that's when it really
gets time-consuming because it's
basically fitting the classifier over
and over again so that's that's sort of
when things get hairy
um I can't really remember but if it's
just like five so so in this case I
think only two in two parameters and I
think I did just just to make sure that
it was sort of generalizable I did it
ten times each I remember being really
impatient while it happened but probably
was just a few minutes maybe 10 minutes
or something like that I don't hardly
remember it was awhile ago sorry yeah
um so you can get it straight from open
street map itself if your area isn't
covered by metro extract and you can in
fact like draw this your own bounding
box and download all the data that's
within that so for mapping data there's
probably one of the best sources
especially in areas where other mapping
data isn't free so I think in the u.s.
mapping data like that's by the
Geological Survey Oh whoever they are
it's supposed to be free but in
Singapore this road data is not free and
and all of this openstreetmap data is
entirely from volunteers you know riding
around on bicycles or things and like
using the GPS to map the roads right
right yeah so so this is good and since
it's very open I mean the fact that it's
that it's so open also is sort of a bad
thing in a way because I mean there's a
lot of my errors and the data that had
to like manually correct like I found
road said did I exist that I think
someone just named after himself so yeah
so you have to be careful of that yeah
okay thank you for coming